Cunningham’s Law is an internet adage that
states “The best way to get the right answer
on the Internet is not to ask a question,
but to post the wrong answer.”
It’s an interesting hypothesis for sure.
And, if you’ve spent any time on the internet
whatsoever, you’re likely well aware that
posting something incorrect online is a sure-fire
way to illicit a smarmy correction from a
fellow internet denizen.
In fact, Today I Found Out wouldn’t exist
if it wasn’t for our deep-seated desire
to correct all of those little urban myths
that float around the internet- there was
(and is) a decided dearth of “interesting
fact” websites that bother to actually do
in-depth research on the “facts” they
purport, let alone ones that included all
the relevant interesting details on the topic
at hand.
Likewise, while it doesn’t happen often
due to several levels of fact checking performed
by the author and a separate fact checker
for each article, when a mistake slips through
the cracks (nobody bats a thousand), it doesn’t
take long for one of our readers or listeners
to post a comment making us aware of the error.
So who was Cunningham of Cunningham’s Law?
In a nutshell, Cunningham is none other than
Ward Cunningham, the man who invented the
“user editable website” or “wiki”
as it’s more commonly known.
Just to be clear, because it’s a fairly
common mistake, Ward doesn’t have anything
directly to do with Wikipedia.
Ward simply developed the first ever wiki
in the mid-1990s, dubbing it “WikiWikiWeb”
after the Wiki Wiki Shuttles he’d encountered
in Honolulu.
The word “wiki” itself is Hawaiian for
“quick” whereas “wiki wiki” means
“very quick”.
(Incidentally, it’s also technically pronounced
we-key, not wick-ey, though given that pretty
much everyone mispronounces it, Cunningham
and others have long stopped correcting people,
ironically enough given the topic at hand.)
From there, wiki software was developed by
Peter Merel, CvWiki, based on WikiWikiWeb’s
engine “WikiBase.”
In turn, Marcus Denker developed AtisWiki
based on CvWiki, then Clifford Adams developed
UseModWiki based on AtisWiki.
This all brings us back to Wikipedia, which
originally used UseModWiki as its platform.
Due to performance issues, among other problems,
this was quickly replaced by a wiki platform
that would come to be called MediaWiki.
This was developed specifically for Wikipedia,
initially by Magnus Manske, then when performance
issues again became an issue, largely re-written
by Lee Daniel Crocker, with many others since
contributing.
In any event, the term “Cunningham’s Law”
first appeared online in 2010 in an issue
of the New York Times as a comment left by
one Steven McGeady, who you may or may not
recognise as a former executive at Intel and
the guy who famously testified against Microsoft
during their 1998 anti-trust trial.
The comment itself was left in response to
an article asking users to submit “novel
eponymous laws” in the same vein as things
like Murphy’s Law or Godwin’s Law, the
latter of which states: “As an online discussion
grows longer, the probability of a comparison
involving Nazis or Hitler approaches 1.”
According to the comment left by McGeady,
Cunningham’s Law was “named after Ward
Cunningham, a colleague of mine at Tektronix.
This was his advice to me in the early 1980s
with reference to what was later dubbed USENET,
but since generalized to the Web and the Internet
as a whole.”
He also goes on to point out the irony of
the relationship between Cunningham, his law,
and the fact that, “Wikipedia is now perhaps
the most widely-known proof of Cunningham’s
Law.”
In short, the Cunningham of Cunningham’s
Law is the guy who invented the first version
of the platform which Wikipedia would ultimately
be based; the law itself began as advice he
gave to people in the 1980s; and the only
reason we know of it today is because someone
he mentioned the idea to talked about it in
the comments of an article online.
We’re going to be honest, we’re kind of
hoping Cunningham at some point comes out
and claims he was misquoted or never actually
said that.
Bonus Fact:
• If you’re wondering, Cunningham never
tried to patent his idea of a wiki because
“I was a small company and I figured, well,
if I got a patent then I’d have to go out
and sell people on the idea that anyone could
edit.
That just sounded like something that no one
would want to pay money for.”
Of course, the platform is used in some form
or another by many thousands of businesses
today (often internally), and many of the
public sites based on it, such as Wikipedia,
have tremendous value.